i'm ryan reynolds i'm jody coma and
we're here to play who's who with
buzzfeed yes we are
no because you're like the nicest guy on
the planet i am not the nicest guy in
the planet inside i am ratchet and
broken glass you're very good at what
you do you're successful you're much
more milly i think in your real life
i mean titanic
is not well taika
runs that same same way yeah yeah but
not he's taika is not uh malevolent in
any way shape or form and he doesn't
wear those god awful snow boots those
incredible shoes
take out style yeah
take away tt for the win
i don't think we've ever tried it but we
have played an impersonation game today
and ryan beat me so i did win although
jody did some very good uh work as a
smurf i think it was microwave a
microwave she did a very good impression
of a microwave
jody i'm most likely to introduce you a
band or a musician you've heard way too
much of i would say maybe joe kiri
because he's like the music mod yeah joe
for sure joe carrey
oh gosh he's a hundred percent one
million percent our costar
yeah definitely do a full week i think
if you could yeah
really i would sing me i would just stop
right in the middle i'm always just like
no this isn't right
um
i'm just gonna try something else
usually i remember giggles because i
feel like oh that got really serious and
everyone kind of hated me for five
minutes because i was wasting time and
money whereas this
felt very kind of free and fun and it
was all kind of part of figuring out
what was going to work
giggle fits were welcomed i had some
giggle fits too
oh for sure
i promise you this is a highly qualified
and highly skilled actor right there oh
disagree uh yeah i don't i'm like let's
try the worst idea first that's a lie
you have like he has like six ideas
all in his back pocket
riffs them all off and every single one
of them lands it's true
[Music]
you and blake i feel like whenever blake
blake loves frank like 100
she could set some sort of rube goldberg
device up on set that ends with a can of
paint landing on my head that's blake
you guys love a prank yeah she looks at
pranks like art um like if you pull a
prank off the right way it's oh it's a
work of art yeah
oh i guess me
really i guess so i've never even seen
you with a phone taika probably because
taika does some pretty
elaborate set selfies when he's on set
they usually involve him laying like
lengthwise on a cot like burt reynolds
cosmopolitan ad in the 70s like
it's just wonderful
100 taika he's known for his naps
famous
anywhere he could be mid-sentence no
problem
how cold for 10 seconds back at it again
i would i would try like at lunch but
there's leather pants and braces and
iron i hear you chest i'm trying to
sleep in a deadpool suit yes
i know the feeling
ryan ryan owns
football club i mean yes i do own a
football club so yeah maybe i maybe
sportsman maybe that doesn't that
doesn't mean anything by the way no i
know but you know there's no indication
of sports acumen whatsoever but i love
sports i played them my whole life so
maybe i don't know not me not me no no
[Music]
yes
yeah honestly though i'm quite an easy
laugh i feel i feel like it doesn't take
much no you you are quick to laugh quick
to laugh is a virtue though i think it's
a really good thing you never want to be
with one of those who's just like no
it's funny
yeah i know it doesn't it doesn't take
much for me it would be really really
good you know you've done a good job if
you've got crow's feet
really intense thank you buzzfeed be
sure to watch free guy in theaters we
hope you enjoy
[Music]
you